les droits fondamentaux
c'est sur les trottoirs du boulevard de
la villette quant à l'architecte en chef
des bonus audio insulté il ferme sa
gueule je me ferai campagne pour vous
stigmatisez et pour vous dites que nenni
la république et apprend 9 fois sur 10
quand vous voyez sur votre petit écran
quelque chose d'important qui s'est
passé à l'assemblée vraiment c'est lcp
d'abord qu'il a repéré et là où on est
fier c'est quand on a travaillé jusqu'au
bout de la nuit
et qu'au petit matin se réveille avec
des matinales radio ou td l'extrait fort
de l'assemblée
parmi les plus gros carton de la chaîne
sur internet c'est la commission d'
enquête sur le coronavirus mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ce pays est infantilisé
il faut quand même un peu se prendre en
main dans ce pays
c'est ça la leçon qu'il faut tirer on a
eu des chiffres historiques sur
l'audition bien sûr du professeur didier
raoul et c'est vrai chez un grand
scientifique je sais ce qui est un essai
et je peux vous dire il ya une dizaine d
traitement que j'ai inventés qui sont
dans tous les livres de référence
médicaux et celui là il sera aussi en
dessous de tout nous on va jamais se
contenter de juste tweet à la surface on
va aussi essayer d'aller toujours au
fond du débat et et en prenant bien sûr
un peu de chaque côté de l'hémicycle
pour avoir toutes les opinions retirer
s'il vous plaît ce gilet
[Applaudissements]
c'est la salle la vidéo de jean lassalle
c'est une vidéo qui a dépassé le million
de vues le journal monsieur la salle
s'il vous plaît allez manifester hors de
cet hémicycle
s'il vous plaît même si bien sûr c'est
un coup politique de la part de jean
lassalle c'était aussi révélateur de
quelque chose de plus profond qui fait
qu'une grande crise allait s'annoncer et
s'était matérialisée par un gilet jaune
sur 577 députés
la séance est suspendue il ya aussi des
débats économiques qui ont été très
suivis comme la privatisation des
aéroports de paris dans le cadre de la
loi pacte
ayez le courage de donner la parole à 44
millions d'électeurs aux français qui
sont les propriétaires de la française
des jeux 10 ans les propriétaires
d'aéroports de paris
[Musique]
sur internet on a tout le temps qu'on
veut voilà on peut aussi bien faire une
vidéo de dix secondes d'une phrase forte
que un débat qui dure huit heures et ça
c'est vrai que sur nos réseaux quand on
est passionné de politique citoyen un
peu curieux ou qu'on a juste envie de se
tenir informé des débats du pays en
suivant lcp on est sûr de trouver notre
honte
[Musique]